yeah this little dog you should just
jump yeah just give me a sec yeah back
to it what's poppin at this moment I
realize he was being sarcastic if you
like fashion you're gonna love this boom
okay carry on my peasants thank you
thank you
wait didn't you do your intro like five
times okay
but this is really intro now put that
Maiko you have orange stuff on your
mouth yeah like the sauce yeah that one
yeah I don't need dental alright so we
are driving to table now and you know
we're still at work
because it is a Thursday and time is it
it's like 12:45 so that's why I'm still
working so see laptop and I'm working
out and film while I work because I need
a camera real quick please can you fill
me hurry up okay okay I got this
Oh
a big one this is some flaw exception
that's good that's good
do you see them I was eating she's our
motto
[Music]
dude did I brought joggers I brought my
ultra boosts you need help I'm gonna do
it I'm doing my hands our fault
[Music]
love seeing houses a little door I
wouldn't about it's so funny I want to
go upstairs
[Music]
[Music]
what does
oh [ __ ] so cool yeah I want the one this
one no you guys are gonna use the door
hello
[Music]
[Music]
I mean if allowed Oh where's that's for
boring yeah ready drop it
wait ah got it oh crap my face
yeah I shouldn't intense vlogger now
I've never even gone career no way they
give you that thank you or Paul for
sponsoring me this obviously Oracle
please sponsor me wait I don't even know
what Oracle does that's sorry sir it's a
database right it's a database probably
databases yeah
[Music]
sweet sweet
yo you know I used to work at McDonald's
oh you said we're working McDonald's and
they taught me how to do the S shape
like this we're popping yeah I don't
think I'll thank you guys know how to do
this I've been trained for a year
wrong
well I'm just dammit
can't throw a me and 4/10 out oh man
why'd you do that
oh no we're having so much fun I hear -
stop it stop it
[Music]